on january 14th family movie night is  getting revamped only on prime video  for centuries no human has had the power  to become a monster  until now  but is this safe though let's find out  [Music]  is everything okay down here hey drac  what's up oops  what's going on i used van helsing's  transforming rain  you're human drag dad  oh no i have a total dead bod  um what is going on  huh  what's up  i'm baldi  [Music]  who are those guys it's me uncle griffin  you don't recognize me i've literally  never seen you before  there is a place deep in the amazon only  there can the transformations be  reversed time to go  stereo man  if we don't fix you guys soon you'll be  like this forever  being a human is the worst  mosquito  hotel transylvania transfer mania  boy that was fun  ready pg coming january 14th only on  prime video